neal
neal
yes honey
neil degrasse tyson i asked you to take
the dog out for a walk when i left the
house four hours ago now i'll come back
and this little mother butt nick has
done pissed on my drapes
now i've got to get rid of those things
and get new ones
neil it doesn't make any sense you're an
astrophysicist
how can you not keep track of little
details like this
well
actually
it's the little details that cannot be
kept track of by definition
in 1927
a german university lecturer named
warner heisenberg came to a seemingly
paradoxical conclusion
that the more we know about the position
of a particle in physical space the less
we know about its momentum and vice
versa
oh okay but what taken in conjunction
with what we know about the expansion of
the universe
this brings us to a fascinating
possibility
that maybe
what we experience as one point in time
space could actually be a lesion of
points
which would mean
that your curtains and little sputnik's
pee-pee could be as distant from one
another as we are from the furthest
galaxy
oh
okay
well just
next time
of course dear
neil
there you are
what are you doing we have to go to my
aunt nelly's funeral
how are you not ready
i've been talking to you about this all
week how am i gonna find you in your
boxers looking at a science magazine
oh i swear neil sometimes i think you
don't have any idea of what's important
well
actually
an idea of what's important is as close
as we can ever come to any definition of
importance
our galaxy is one of over a hundred
billion in the observable universe
and it's a hundred thousand light years
across
which means it would take light 100 000
years to traverse
okay but but that's just space
if we were to chart
the history of the universe on one
calendar year the history of mankind as
we know it would just take place in the
final second of that year so
whether i'm ready now or in 500 years
well
cosmically speaking the distinction is
meaningless
well okay
[Music]
i'm i'm going now
goodbye honey
who is she
who is the white [ __ ] that left this
goddamn lipstick stain on your collar
hmm
oh i got you
you're caught
because this is apricot colored and you
know who wears that white [ __ ]
and you can't talk your way out of this
one cause i'm not getting confused today
because i got my order and i've done my
research okay neil
you see
we are here at this point in space time
on a human scale but at this point you
would triflin ass mother
so expect the papers from the lawyer
because we're part in ways
[Music]
well actually
no
no
we are always parting ways and not
parting ways in every conceivable
combination
many physicists including stephen
hawking now believe that there is an
infinite number of universes
it's called multiverse theory
and it suggests that there are an
infinite number of universes in which
i didn't have sex with that white woman
bill nye the science guy you [ __ ]